you welcome to this video this is plus
plus okay and I go g6 yeah of course
that set should be if i'm not mistaken
the final video of that opening week the
fianchetto oh he says nice videos yeah
so I got people off some people here
watch my stuff same as the guy before
and that was very generous to him
donating a full point let's see what we
got here yet another modern defense and
um I'm trying form let's shoot for that
quick c5 I had an earlier game way I got
something like a turbocharged dragon out
of it and this might happen here as well
oh just for treating okay I'm taking
that and I get to this kind of Dragon
scenario yeah and d5 that's great now
just a nice position cheeks night eggs I
wonder now Bishop h6e can play it's not
so bad that he has to do that
now maybe takes on d5 and brush-up age 6
nothing nothing great but you can do
that it's not not terrible wow it's
actually allowing that okay I'm all all
out for that why not 95 if a jig first
if I tq4 let's look at that it's not
really clear what he what he is doing
about it no I guess not be five at the
end of a tick with the night only 495
was actually what I was thinking but
maybe queen before as possible yeah
let's just play the position and not do
anything fancy i also have a good square
on a fire for my night and 95 is now
really on I think okay now that's a good
night c4 is in and night xf3
so look at the 8th 1st or look 28 or 93
Knight f3 pawn takes d5 is a piece so he
has to check back with the night which
is nice for me but let's do that that is
threatening a couple of things that rook
takes d4 for example is probably a
threat rooty for Bishop b5 rookie to
Quincy 751 set a threat no just trade
stuff okay huh I'm a chick now I can at
least win this pawn down
check let's take it and has to take with
an item otherwise e 50 is Queen f3e five
Bishop g5 mm looks like a very weird
idea but now let it go for that so I'm
grabbing this stuff Brooksie one is
sister is very some actually a little
bit but I have Queen aid
oopsie 7 we should be form
now he has to get something in the next
two or three moves otherwise it's just
over I'm a very healthy pawn up and I
have two bishops so you have to get
something like now or never and I'm
threatening only form so Luke c7 Bishop
before I takes Knight takes rook e7 or
something like that but I have Bishop f8
probably for Bishop c5 later now that
doesn't look good but what there's
something else Bishop c7 as a
self-penned after Luke c8 it's really
bad really jumping into that night yeah
okay let's not be too quick here I mean
that looks nice but still sugar 3
knocking that's just good let's do that
he has to go Queen D for just that I
wondered hey i want it i should really
win win material but I don't somehow I
don't
fatigue f3 let's let's f 4 i'm sorry and
now i can take here on f3
now let's do that trade trade rooks
trading looks just as good look-see for
here
yeah I wanted I don't want to give up
the bishop pair but I'm centralizing so
nicely after that I think it's probably
worth it yeah I thought f5 but he has
queen bee aid it's a bit uncomfortable
came for Roxy to check how you can check
me again I'm morning okay it's not a big
deal I can play back Bishop f6
check
I bishop f2 is got Queen a form that
sets bad okay let's do this kind of I'm
not playing this well I had much better
position before okay i will probably win
that on time but i had a much better
position his Alliance screwed that up a
little bit yeah it was a again a very
nice position out of the opening like a
beginner super version of a Sicilian
it's a bit awkward this position for
what already this I thought this may be
but yeah I had seen that but I wasn't
sure how good it is it looks nice yeah
he also has weak dark squares if he goes
back like rook to aid for 95 or
something like that or a 593 lat just
very nice here yeah okay at the engine
actually responds to check the porn okay
I was thinking he has discoveries but
well I have b2 and c2 on that check yeah
this I didn't really follow up on that
that's just good that's not a bad move
it isn't here rook e8 that the don't
make sense I think no here yeah I think
just the best best continuation took him
blackest black ass is just winning here
actually and I wasn't totally sure
because of like a Lucas is seven but I
really can just take there is no this is
an easy win and here I have chest
intermedia check which is quite neat
which edition see actually but it's very
strong yeah yeah around here I can
certainly improve rook c8 is actually
engine but probably probably this isn't
great that is winning yeah I can just
take the pawn why didn't I just take it
that was would have been easier check
let's check okay the engine always gives
gives me more than one pawn so it isn't
it isn't it wasn't so bad what I did
yeah again that was a nice version of
the modern wear white was losing here
quite a bit of time with his nights here
jumping around and in the meantime I got
a Sicilian kind of position which really
is nice white has lost time so good
result there okay that was a final game
of this of this opening week of the
Kings fianchetto and make sure to watch
the revenue video of that week to get a
more comprehensive picture of this type
of opening thanks for watching